[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so we're here today to remember the past  officials young people of color it's  person worse because we're in the  frontlines of the crisis I think it's  important that we stand together because  our future depends on it  we need to make sure that our elected  officials acknowledge that climate  change does exist the more they deny it  or bleak our future  we have to stop burning fossil fuels and  we have to ensure that we're protecting  the most vulnerable people in our  communities the devastation that we're  seeing from these hurricanes from these  wildfires is not sustainable the good  thing is that there are many solutions  to climate change and all these start  with moving over to a hundred percent  renewable energy